the theories of energy by nikola tesla
have been revolutionary to say the least
but for some mysterious reason history
does not dwell enough on his story
the us government sat on tesla's entire
estate for 10 years did they keep any of
his papers
i read that some people claim that tesla
saw the great pyramid as a power
generator
all the pyramids had an explosion and
maybe all at the same time
did you know that the word pirro mean in
latin means fire in the middle
crashed into one of the towers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
before tesla you could only send
electricity one mile just for lighting
after tesla you could run factories for
500 600 miles in all directions if they
get a story and they repeat it over and
over they have no proof of any of it
they never found a mummy in a pyramid
did nikola tesla find the secret to
unlimited energy
and is there a plot to hide his findings
energy
the ultimate power
when i think about it i find that most
wars that have been waged in the past
years have been about the control of
what provides energy
and if i'm to talk about energy then i
must mention nikola tesla
i still remember my physics teacher at
school saying that tesla was an
exceptional genius whose work is behind
many important inventions
the story of energy might be quite
mysterious
tesla was a scientist but some people
say that he was mystical
they claim he believed the egyptian
great pyramids were key to limitless
energy
an energy that could be distributed to
everyone in the world for free
he was a controversial personality even
after his death
they say that after he died alone in his
hotel room in new york
the fbi confiscated all his belongings
taking all his documents with them
and for many years
they say they were classified and even
until now many people claim there are
documents missing
who was nikola tesla
was he really a genius
what is the difference between him and
the famous inventor thomas edison
i think the best person to answer this
is dr mark safer
writer and university lecturer
who also authored the book wizard the
life and times of nikola tesla
hi mark thank you for meeting me thank
you
the first question i have is
who was nikola tesla nikola tesler was
born in 1856
in smilian croatia he studied at the
university of graz which was like the
mit of austria in those days he was a
mathematical genius and he eventually
moved to the united states to work for
tom edison things didn't work out too
well and then he moved out on his own
can you tell me what was his greatest
accomplishments
and i don't think it's just one i think
there's at least three
major inventions the first is the
induction motor and what tesla figured
out was how to harness alternating
current before tesla you could only send
electricity one mile power dropping off
over distance just for lighting after
tesla you could put a one uh
hydroelectric power system he's the
inventor of the hydroelectric power
system and you could
you could run factories before 500 600
miles in all directions he also invented
wireless communication he invented what
became the radio and cell phone
technology the ability to multiply
frequencies and created an unlimited
number of wireless channels we talk
about hertz waves but they're not really
hurts waves they're tesla waves all of
our computer systems uh run on the
binary code and he really is the
forerunner to all that so i think those
are his three major inventions that's
really big
in your opinion what makes him different
from other inventors like edison for
example
in general edison built better mouse
traps the light bulb existed before
edison perfected the light bulb motion
picture cameras existed he built the
best one tesla himself distinguished
from edison because tesla said i
discovered new principles he was able to
transmit voice by means of wireless
communication that was a new principle
one of tesla's most spectacular projects
was the warden cliff tower that was in
new york
with it he wanted to send wireless
electricity across the globe
what can you tell me about tesla's
towers
it's a very sad story in in 1898 he was
doing big experiments in downtown new
york city and it was scary so he moved
all the way out to colorado to to test
his wireless uh inventions and met with
jp morgan
and morgan gave him 150 000
to uh build a tower tesla read an
article that marconi was using his
equipment and he freaked out so he
doubled the size of the tower because he
figured i'm not gonna just send impulses
from new york to london if i build a
tower twice that high they can send it
all over the world and morgan make even
more money
so morgan was in europe at the time and
when morgan returned he found out that
tesla ran out of money but he'd also
doubled the size of the tower from 90
feet to 180 feet
so that was one of the reasons morgan
pulled the funding but morgan didn't
just pull the funding he blocked other
investors and the reason he blocked
tesla i think is because he was partly
afraid that maybe tesla was right
maybe you could send electrical power
without wires and morgan had rubber
plantations you know you have the rubber
around the wires he had copper mines he
had lumber yards he wanted telephone
poles he wanted wires he wanted to sell
copper he wanted to sell rubber
after tesla died what happened to his
inventions and documents and manuscripts
the us government sat on tesla's entire
estate for 10 years so from 1943 to
about 1952 until they finally released
it and now his estate is in belgrade and
the question that you're really asking
is did they keep any of his papers i
don't know if they did
and it wouldn't surprise me if indeed
that has occurred
i read that some people claim that tesla
saw the great pyramid as a power
generator they say that
he built his tower that generates power
from nature using the same engineering
principles as the ones used to build the
great pyramid have you considered that
this could be
nonsense
this is a good question of course
and i may just know someone who could
answer it
why are there people who believe there
is a strong connection between the great
pyramids and great energy
the film producer and director carmen
bolter made a five-part documentary
titled the pyramid code which focuses on
the pyramids and other ancient
structures in egypt
i watched this documentary series to
search for new information
nikola tesla sought to provide the world
with free wireless electricity for
everybody on earth he discovered that
electricity occurred naturally
throughout the earth's atmosphere and
ground
this energy was not the kind of energy
that we have that pollutes it was a
completely
passive energy that had no byproducts
if the pyramid fields and the network of
underground tunnels are still there
why don't they generate energy the way
they used to
what did tesla see in the pyramids other
than they are giant tombs
i'd like to ask carmen this question
hi
carmen carmen can you explain to me why
do you think
the great pyramids of giza in egypt
were not tombs it has nothing to do with
that and they keep repeating they get a
story and they repeat it over and over
and they get the students to repeat it
to get their mark
to get out of college and none of it
they have no proof of any of it they
never found a mummy in a pyramid
why do you think they were power
generators
christopher dunn has shown how the
pyramids could have been used as energy
plant
he's written several books uh the giza
power plant he's an engineer and so his
research isn't psychic and you know
esoteric in any way it's mechanical and
he's done a very good job of showing
how
energy could have been collected and
that's what part of the weird chemical
marks that you see
[Music]
all the pyramids had an explosion and
maybe all at the same time and huge
cracks are in these stones that are like
300 tons you know so how do you crack
through the entire stone without this
force and in the great pyramid in the
king's chamber there's like a crack in
the wall and the side of the sarcophagus
is blown right off
and that's like four inches thick of
pure granite which is very hard so if we
went in there with sledgehammers and 100
people we couldn't break it that way
it's funny that you say that because
did you know that the word piro mead
in latin means fire in the middle
[Music]
did tesla use ancient egyptian theories
in his work
is there a similarity between tesla's
towers of wireless energy and the
pyramids
danny kerr has done a lot of research on
the pyramids and energy he may have some
answers
hi danny how do you think the pyramids
generated energy i went to look at the
inside of the great pyramid and try and
figure out how it worked and what i
realized was
there was a gentleman named john cadman
he's a hydrologist and he had shown that
the great pyramid couldn't be like a
pulse generator he showed how the it
created water hammer and could pump
water when i first saw his theory i
realized right away that the
granite plugs that are in the start of
the ascending passages that those would
move the pyramids uh had perimeter walls
around them and i didn't know this
before and it's accepted by
egyptologists and they say it was to
keep thieves out and what he was saying
was it was to keep water in
that was really interesting and so the
water level of the pyramid would be
above
the uh ascending passage
girdle stones and so the water would
have built up above them the second you
start a pulse inside it pushes water up
and from there the pressure increase
just did work on the king's chamber then
once i um i just started to investigate
how a motor would work
that like this
um with a pressure change inside came
across thermo-acoustic engines
can you now please tell me similarities
between tesla's warden cliff tower and
the giza pyramids apparently tesla said
his warden cliff tower uh he was using a
longitudinal wave or he was outputting a
longitudinal electric wave
and technically it's not possible no
one's figured that out
in the pyramids they're producing loud
vibrations that mix to produce
longitudinal waves it's very similar
also the pyramids in egypt and the
warden cliff tower are both built on
aquifers
with the warning cliff tower the water
was there to aid the grounding he was
transmitting through ground and the
water lowered the resistance in the
ground and made it a conductor the
pyramids that's also the case not only
are they water powered they are built
above an aquifer and they had uh they
were satin pools we think
tesla's warning clefthouse was low
frequency so is a great pyramid that's
another similarity both have the
capability to transmit worldwide
it seems that there can be a similarity
in principles between the energy tower
built by tesla and the great pyramids
built by ancient egyptians
could this be a coincidence
and why has there been no one until
today who tried using this technology
these are questions that require another
journey to search for answers
[Music]
energy is simply power
that's why i see the most important
structures today are not palaces or
skyscrapers or cemeteries
i think structures like dams oil rigs
and nuclear power plants are the most
important
because these are the factories of
energy hence power
yet when we look at the great pyramids
of giza are we supposed to think they
were no more than giant tombs
if financing tesla hadn't stopped
he could have succeeded in providing the
world with clean energy at low cost
does that mean tesla could have changed
the world
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you